so we've got sharpie gate which we'll
follow up on a little bit later it now
appears that it wasn't merely that
Donald Trump held up a Sharpie modified
hurricane map we're now getting reports
from White House insiders that Donald
Trump personally sharp heed the
hurricane map itself there's one problem
with that claim and I'll talk about it
later in the show but before we even get
to that Donald Trump had a completely
separate and crazed and erratic fit on
Twitter over the weekend starting about
Barack Obama
now remember when Barack Obama was
president I know many of you do
Republicans wouldn't stop saying hey
Democrats george w bush isn't president
anymore
don't mention george w bush just talk
about Barack Obama no more talk about
Bush I wish one of them would be
intellectually honest enough to give the
same advice to Donald Trump and
Republicans now Barack Obama's not
president anymore Hillary Clinton never
was president stop talking about both of
them but Donald Trump going off on
Twitter on Barack Obama shifting
directly from that Twitter tirade into
yes one related to Hurricane Dorian and
the map and fake news so disclaimer
before we get into this I've said before
many times we don't want to just cover
Trump tweets for the sake of covering
Trump tweets and we don't and in fact
today I'm gonna skip over a ton of them
because they're not really related it's
theirs tweets that are differently
incoherent which are not particularly
relevant to the story we're talking
about today today I'm gonna focus on
specifically Trump's tweets about Obama
and the Alabama stuff and fake news now
all of what I'm going to show you
happened basically within 24 hours not
even early this weekend so understand
this is sort of about the content of the
tweets but this is happening in one day
this is one day of some of Donald
Trump's tweets this is the president
look at the emotional instability look
at the amount of time that is being
spent tweeting falsehoods instead of
being president so let's just jump right
into it starting off with the
immigration stuff and Obama the you
migration law institute's Christopher
Heydrich says the Supreme Court has to
look at whether daca is lawful what they
are looking at now is whether Trump's
rescission of daca is lawful must
consider lawfulness of daca itself look
very odd that President Trump doesn't
have the discretion to end the program
that President Obama began in his
discretion already I mean the language
is crazy it's all crazy that program was
unlawful to begin with I think it's very
unlikely that the Supreme Court is going
to issue an order reinstating what it
believes is an unlawful program daca is
unlawful
President Obama never had the legal
right to sign daca and he indicated so
at the time of signing but in any event
how can he have the right to sign and I
don't have the right to unsigned totally
illegal document which would actually
give the president new powers daca will
be going before the Supreme Court it is
a document that even President Obama
didn't feel he had the legal right to
sign he signed it anyway I mean this is
incoherent folks rest assured that if
the Supreme Court does would all say it
must based on the law a bipartisan deal
will be made the benefit of all so this
is the Obama daca rant and it makes no
sense at all Obama didn't sign daca it
was a presidential memo to expand
something that already existed there are
more details but this is not a story
about immigration it is about the
unhinged and unstable nature of the
president so there are four tweets
they're just rants they mean nothing of
substance but his followers see that as
strong leadership believe it or not so
then a few hours go by and Donald Trump
tweets about the fed another popular
target going from slamming Obama to
slamming the Fed saying quote I agree
with Jim Cramer the Fed should lower
rates they were way too early to raise
and way too late to cut and big dose
quantitative tightening didn't exactly
help either where did I find this guide
Jerome oh well you can't win them all so
when he says where did I find this guy
Jerome he's talking about Fed chief
Jerome Powell who of course Trump picked
after bragging that one of the hallmarks
of his administration would be
appointing the best people if Jerome's
not great
then it's on Trump now we're up to five
tweets then he tweets some compliments
about Fox News people Sarah Huckabee
Sanders newly a contributor Jeanine
Pirro I'm not even including those then
he goes back to the hurricane and
remember this is all the same day quote
the fake news media was fixated on
fact that I properly said at the
beginnings of Hurricane Dorian that in
addition to Florida and other states
Alabama may also be grazed or hit they
went capital C crazy hoping against hope
that I made a mistake which I didn't
check out Maps this nonsense has never
happened to another president because
other presidents aren't doing what
you're doing four days of corrupt
reporting still without an apology but
there are many things that the fake news
media has not apologized to me for like
the witch hunter Spygate the lamestream
media and their Democrat partner should
start playing it straight it would be so
much better for our country so we're now
up to eight tweets once again sort of
amalgamating the issues of so-called
fake news
the hurricane dorian fiasco making
himself out to be the victim and martyr
and calling the russia probe a hoax
conspiracy this is still one day friday
then tweet 9 in this series is trump
again attacking the so-called fake news
quote the economy is great the only
thing adding to quote uncertainty is the
fake news that's tweet 9 and it's still
september 6th and i'm not including the
ones about puro and sanders and then he
goes into false statements about tariffs
quote china just enacted a major
stimulus plan with all the tariffs they
are paying to the USA billions and
billions of dollars they need it in the
meantime our Federal Reserve sits back
and does nothing now of course China
doesn't pay the tariffs American
companies buying Chinese stuff pay the
tariffs and then they pass on the cost
of those tariffs onto you and me
American consumers that's the tenth
tweet and these are just the policy ones
again he also spent half the day
tweeting compliments to a variety of Fox
News hosts stop talking about Obama stop
lying about how tariffs work stop lying
about investigative journalism being
fake news stop lying about Hurricane
Dorian Trump is trying to bully society
and the economy into some kind of stupid
submission by attacking media and using
Twitter and they're not fully submitting
to him some enclaves have submitted to
Trump that's sad that's disappointing if
we do not vote this out in November
of 2020 we deserve another four years of
this as a society now I know the people
who vote for someone else they don't
personally deserve it but if as a
country we cannot eradicate the type of
pseudo and anti intellectualism
and non thinking hyper partisan a
sticking like glue
to this incompetent man then as a
society as a country we ultimately will
deserve another four years of this which
is what we might get let me know what
you think about all of this are you just
depressed
are you experiencing something else I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show have you
ever wondered why traditional button ups
look so long and baggy it's because they
were not meant to be worn untucked
untuck it is the brand you've been
looking for because they were
specifically designed to be worn
untucked this is the original untucked
shirt it's a modern solution to an old
problem
no tucking or tailoring required no
matter your size or shape these shirts
are the perfect untucked length with
more than 50 fit combinations untuck it
shirts look great on tall short slim and
athletic guys of all ages
you can shop online or visit one of
untuk 'its stores I have a bunch of
untucked shirts now they fit perfectly
untucked not too long everybody that
sees them says where'd you get that
shirt and I gladly tell them untuck it
fits my frame perfectly and the
materials are great the color options
are fantastic try it on in person at one
of untuck it's fifty stores or just go
to untuck it calm to get started they
even offer free shipping and returns on
all orders in the United States and you
can save 20% on your first order by
using my code Pakman at checkout that's
un tu ck i t dot com promo code Pakman